how are you greetings I enter Mejía with his
brief information and it is Thursday, September 30,
the board of directors of
the higher education system is
considering whether it is going to force its
employees to be fully vaccinated
by December 1st. The decision would
impact the public university sector
if this  approved workers
would face layoffs and do not
meet the requirement the board
is also evaluating
religious or medical exemptions will be offered
currently a fifth of the
workforce of its employees are not
vaccinated
the self-service vaccination and testing clinic
at the university  is
being relocated the change will be made this
coming monday the clinic will be moved
from the building they have merged
parking lot in the center tablet is
marked the hours will be from sunday to
thursday from 5:30 pm to 10:30
pm
and at night  third consecutive week the
number of unemployment applications is
increasing at a level  The national economists
believe that it could be due to the
coronavirus Ceuta in the state of Nevada
1,700 new applications were registered
in total the figure stands at 11,000
and tomorrow is the fourth anniversary of the
massacre on October 1
58 people were killed by a
shooter  the night of the outdoor
concert here in las vegas' two other
victims lost their lives years
later the sunrise ceremony returns
to the county government center the
names of the victims will be read in
another ceremony
at the memorial garden downtown
survivors will also form a
human chain
and now we start with the weather conditions
another nice day is expected
with a high of only 84 degrees and
here you go the next few days
hope the smoke from the
wildfires will stay out of the area
for the end of  week warmer temperatures
with a slight chance of
thunderstorms next week  Have a
nice day I am Héctor Mejía and this was
your brief information on teaching in
Spanish
[Music]